-My first guest is the host of
"Late Night with Seth Meyers,"
which airs weeknights on NBC
right after our show
and is also available
on Peacock.
Please welcome Seth Meyers,
ladies and gentlemen!
-♪ Seth Adam Meyers
wasn't hard to book ♪
♪ If you don't know the reason,
you need to take a closer look ♪
♪ If you know Seth Meyers
and can't get enough ♪
♪ Stay on this channel,
he's on right after us ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
-Oh!
-That's got to feel great, huh?
-It's nice -- You know,
we haven't done it yet.
So to be in front of an audience
again, my goodness.
-It's unbelievable.
Yeah, they're the best.
Thank you guys.
-Yeah, real, live
[ Cheers and applause ]
Real, live human beings.
-Yeah, I --
Thank you for coming down
and doing the show with us.
I know --
-You make it very easy.
It's two floors.
[ Laughter ]
-The family's good?
Alexi's good?
-Yeah, the kids are great.
-Yeah.
-I mean, they're great. Right?
-No, I just want
to establish that
before I keep going.
-Yeah, of course.
-I don't --
You know, I like my time
with them to be positive.
But I would like this time now
to sort of air some grievances.
-Oh, really?
-Just minor things.
-Sure.
-'Cause I don't --
I feel like they watch late-
night TV, so they'll see this,
and it's just easier for me
if they hear it this way.
-No, of course, of course.
So smart. Yes.
-So, they --
I have two beautiful boys.
-Yeah, I know, I love them.
-Their smiles light up a room.
-Yeah.
-The most natural, angelic,
cherubic smiles.
-Yes.
-You take out a camera --
Crazy rictus grins.
It's like --
We have no good photos
of them smiling,
'cause they're like
laughing and being real,
and then it's like
they got bit by a scorpion.
And they're like --
-Dude, that is weird.
Why do --
-It's awful.
-My kids do that, too.
-And I show it to them
on the phone, I'm like, "I can't
let people look at this.
You understand?"
[ Laughter ]
-You're too cute for this.
-"You're too cute --
You're better than this, guys."
-Yes! That's it. But they're
learning how to smile.
-They're learning -- It's so
weird that they don't --
Yeah, they just hate --
-We've learned over the years,
you go like, "Smile for a
picture."
-Yeah, I show like, I show them
adults on Instagram.
I'm like, "None of these people
are really happy.
They've just learned --
They've learned to fake it.
-Yes!
-Come on, guys!
[ Laughter ]
-Awful.
-Awful, well, yeah.
-I hope you're watching.
-They're the cutest kids
in the world.
-They're two good dudes.
-You're doing stand-up
shows again.
-Yeah. I've done a couple.
It's really nice.
People are so happy
to just be out.
-Yeah, how does it feel
to perform?
-It's great. I did stand-up
in a tent in a parking lot,
and it was wonderful.
And I think that speaks to how
lousy the last year has been.
-Yeah.
-That you feel like
you're walking into
a night club,
when you're like, "Look at this.
A tent in a parking lot!"
-"Look at that!"
-"Oh!
Top of the world!"
-"You did this for me!"
-Yeah, but it's really fun.
And I think these
next few years, I think
live performance, live music,
people are just going to be --
Sports. Everybody's going to be
happy to be in the same place,
which is cool.
-Yeah, I know you're doing
a gig in Boston soon.
-Yes. Yeah, July.
-Where are you playing?
-The Wilbur? You know the --
The best, right?
-I think I recorded
a comedy thing there.
-Yeah, you did.
-It's one of the best theaters
in the country.
-So I'm looking forward to that.
And of course --
-I mean, you're Boston,
I mean, you're --
-I'm, you know, Southern
New Hampshire, which we count --
We say is Boston, and Boston
says, "No, you're not."
[ Laughter ]
-But that's Boston.
-That's Boston, right.
-But I know -- I think you are
the biggest Red Sox fan.
-I had a run there where I think
no one cared more
about the Red Sox than I did.
-Maybe Mike Schur.
-Mike Schur, our dear friend
who worked at "SNL" with us
and then went on to --
Nothing. To just fail.
[ Laughter ]
-No, he did "The Office."
-"The Office," "Parks and Rec,"
"The Good Place."
-He's one of our friends.
-He does an incredible job,
yeah.
-Yeah, he's brilliant.
But do you remember
when we went out drinking
one night with David Wells?
-Yeah. I mean,
you guys know David Wells.
-One of the best pitchers
in the history of baseball.
-And one of the greatest
partiers of all time.
-He's a Yankee, New York --
He's a legend.
And he was so much fun.
We used to hang out with him
whenever we got a chance.
-Yep.
-And then we went out,
I go, "Seth, let's just do it.
Wellsie's around. Let's do it."
-And we had an incredible night
with David Wells.
-He's unbelievable, though.
-He's unbelievable.
The thing about him is, and I
don't know if you found this.
I felt like when you went out
and drank with David Wells,
he would tell you
all the secrets of baseball.
Like, it felt like
he was giving you
all the mysteries of the sport.
-Yeah.
-And yet with each mystery,
he'd also make do you a shot.
[ Laughter ]
And so the next morning,
you'd wake up,
and it was all gone.
-Couldn't remember anything.
-You couldn't remember
any of it.
That's how he gets you.
-Yeah, because I do remember him
having great stories,
but right off
the top of my head,
I don't remember
any of the great stories.
But he's such a good hang.
But we went out --
-We went out, and I made the
mistake of texting Mike Schur,
who's another dyed-in-the-wool
Red Sox fan.
And he was so upset to hear
that I was out with a Yankee.
And this is before the Red Sox
won the World Series.
So we were a little bit
more irrational.
And I came in the next day,
and he had gone to
the New York Yankees store,
which is right around here
where they just sell merch.
-That's right.
-And he had --
This is the way he burned me.
He spent $500 on Yankees stuff
and filled my office.
-I mean, the ceiling,
everything.
-Pillows.
There was a Yankee lamp.
-No, the best move was,
do you remember,
your screen saver was Yankees.
-Yeah, screen saver.
A Yankee mouse pad.
-No, he took it
to the next level.
He's like, "Oh, Mr. Yankee.
Come on in.
You love the Yankees so much.
You go out drinking with them.
Why don't you come in?"
-He was like,
"I thought you'd enjoy --
Consider this a parting gift,
as you are now dead to me."
-I think on the front
of the door was either Wells
or somebody, or Jeter,
or somebody.
-It was --
He did not react well.
We got over it. We got over it.
-Dude, congrats on "Late Night."
How many years has it been now,
seven years?
-Seven. Isn't that nuts?
I mean, yeah.
-Ah, I'm so happy.
-Seven years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're kicking butt.
The show's fantastic.
You're as sharp as ever.
The writing is awesome.
-Those guys do
an amazing job, yeah.
-Are you loving it?
-Yeah! I mean, I can't believe,
you know, especially
this last year.
I've always felt incredibly
grateful to have a show.
But this last year
has been insane
to be able to still
go and do your job
even though this year
has been such a drag.
And so I felt --
-Thank you for doing it.
We all needed it.
-Thank you, buddy.
-I mean, everyone needed it,
and so, yeah.
Just for you being there
and showing up was one thing,
but then doing great comedy and
good work, we're like, "Yes!
Thank you.
Just get us through this."
-Well, it was an honor
to just be a part
of all the late night shows.
We're getting it done.
-We love you, bud. I'm so happy.
-Thank you.
-Thanks for coming on the show.
Seth Meyers.
You can catch "Late Night with
Seth Meyers" on NBC and Peacock
right after our show.
Just don't change the channel.
-Yeah.
-You'll see more of Seth.